واعرب ناصر ابو بكر نقيب الصحفيين
الفلسطينيين عن امله ان تفضي التحقيقات
التي تقوم بها لجنه التحقيق الامميه بشان
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله بما في ذلك
القدس الشرقيه واسرائيل الى توصيات لتحويل
ملف الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه بحق الصحفيين
الفلسطينيين لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه
وشدد ناصر ابو بكر على ضروره منح الحصانه
الكامله للصحافيين الفلسطينيين اثناء
اداءهم همهم جاء ذلك في تصحيح للجزيره
قبيل الادلائه بشهادته امام اللجنه في
جنان
نامل من هذا التقرير ان توصل لجنه التحقيق
بان يحول الى ملف محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
نريد ان نحول هذا التقرير ويكون وثيقه
دوليه من احد مؤسسات الامم المتحده نعتمد
به ونذهب به الى ملفنا في محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه في قتل شيرين ابو عقله وياسر
مرتجى واحمد ابو حسين واصابه العديد من
الصحفيين منهم معاذ عمامنا ونضال اجتيا
وبالتالي نريد ان نحسن هذا التقرير جئنا
الى هنا الى جنيف لنضع اللجنه بالواقع
الحقيقي والجرائم اليوميه التي ترتكب بحق
الصحفيين الفلسطينيين